divide x squared minus 3x plus 2 divided
by X minus 2 so we're going to divide
this into that and we could do this
really the same way that you first learn
long division so we have X minus 2 being
divided into x squared minus 3x plus 2
another way we could have written the
same exact expression is x squared minus
3x plus 2 all of that over X minus 2
that that and that are all equivalent
expressions now to do this type of long
division we can call it algebraic long
division you want to look at the highest
degree term on the x minus 2 and the
highest degree term on the x squared
minus 3x plus 2 and here's the X and
here's the x squared X goes into x
squared how many times or x squared
divided by X is what well that's just
equal to X so X goes into x squared x
times I'm going to write it in this
column right here above all of the X
terms and then we want to multiply x
times X minus 2 that gives us x times X
is x squared x times negative 2 is
negative 2x and just like you first
learned in long division you want to
subtract this from that so you want to
subtract this from that but that's
completely the same as adding the
opposite or multiplying each of these
terms by negative 1 and then adding so
let's multiply that times negative 1 and
negative 2 x times negative 1 is
positive 2x and now let's add x squared
minus x squared those cancel out
negative 3x plus 2x that is negative x
and then we can bring down this 2 over
here so it's negative x plus 2 left over
when we only go x times so then we take
an X minus 2 going to negative x plus 2
well X goes into negative x negative 1
times negative 1 you could look at it
right here negative x divided by X is
negative 1 these guys cancel out those
guys cancel out so negative 1 times X
minus 2 you have negative 1 times X
which is negative x negative 1 times
negative 2 is positive 2 and we want to
subtract this from that just like you do
in long division but that's the same
thing as multiplying the opposite or
multiplying each of these terms
by negative one and then adding so
negative x times negative one is
positive x positive two times negative
one is a positive 2 times negative 1 is
negative 2 these guys cancel out add up
to 0 these guys set up to 0 we have no
remainder so we got this as being equal
to X X minus 1 and we can verify it if
we multiply X minus 1 times X minus 2 we
should get this so let's actually do
that so if we let's multiply X minus 1
times X minus 2 so let's multiply
negative 2 times negative 1 that gives
us positive 2 negative 2 times X that's
negative 2x let's multiply x times
negative 1 that is negative x and then x
times X is x squared and then add all
the like terms x squared negative 2x
minus X that's negative 3x and then 2
plus nothing is just 2 and so we got
that polynomial again